now I'm going to introduce somebody that
actually needs no introduction but I'm
gonna do it anyway
you remember him as limo driver in 1994
is future shock you sort of remember him
as paramedic number two in 1999's kit
rescue 77 in in 1998 Smike hammers
Private Eye you loved him as agent in a
neighboring office Greg I got these off
by MTP that's and my favorite in Austin
Powers Goldmember who can forget about
shirtless fan and of course you know you
remember I've been everything that JJ
Abrams has ever directed produced
written and finally they've beloved at
the beloved Matt Parkman in a you know a
little-known TV show called heroes
ladies and gentlemen
Oh psyched are we to be here I remember
when we were here the first time and I I
do not believe Tim you had a Twitter
account back then did you okay if you're
not following Tim first of all follow
Greg Grunberg that's the most important
person oh my god I love each and every
one of you in this room I really do
I've been here since Thursday I'm
walking the halls or it easy
you guys are so wonderful and thank you
for coming up and hugging and you know
thank you for brushing your teeth
everything it's been wonderful
tim is gonna send out his first official
tweet so everybody's gonna be in and
let's bring up the lights we're gonna do
a selfie and everybody's gonna be in it
that's pretty good gasps are you guys
ready for heroes reborn
I am I am I have a question for you Tim
City you're Mike my friend this is this
is an important question
so when heroes when we first started we
were here and we got an incredible
reception much like this and it was
unbelievable and we kind of set the tone
for TV that now their shows on they're
just blowing all of us away how do you
bring the show back knowing that the bar
is so much higher and by the way I have
seen stuff and we've gotten race through
this because we have great stuff to show
you guys tonight some people introduce
but this is heroes on steroids how did
you do it how did you figure out it like
what was the inspiration you know this
is that guys the challenge the challenge
is that since we came along we looked
and felt like nothing else on TV and now
two shows are out there that we have to
compete with the show first and foremost
has always been about the characters and
so that's what set it apart and you know
it was not necessarily about the
superpowers is about the characters of
dealing with it with with these
abilities that they had that being said
there are certain things that have
gotten a lot easier to do than when we
first started nine years ago I mean
people are doing special effects
literally on the set with a laptop that
we used to take you know three weeks of
endless you know waiting around for so
you know and cameras have gotten lighter
and the lighting packages have gotten
smaller and we've you know we've been
able to last time with here as we only
filmed I think we probably never
45 miles circle from where we were in
Los Angeles and yet we created all these
worlds around the you know all over the
place yeah this time we are gonna you
know real will to shot in Iceland in
Canada at Los Angeles in Tokyo in Paris
and so you know it's it's a very
different it's also an indication of how
much support we're getting NBC is 1000%
behind this let's hear it for NBC
because you know I get people coming up
to me all the time including my mom and
saying what what the hell happened like
we were we were on a roll we were doing
great and then the show went off the air
so creatively I look at it like it's a
tremendous opportunity because you
didn't wrap things up necessarily and
you can just pick is that what we're
doing we're cooking it up where we left
off yeah we actually are picking up
exactly five you know chronological time
five years from where we left off and so
you know we ended with Claire Bennet
exposing these powers to the worlds or
coming out and and so now everybody
knows about these powers and sure enough
when we start five years later the
entire world knows about these powers
and is and it's not such a good thing
okay enough say you guys want to see
something that's kick-ass this is the
extended trailer no one's seen this yet
it's pretty grim I know you guys are
excited
no one's getting a lightsaber there's no
concert I can tell you that right now
to get JJ but I've got the con so here
we go guys welcome to this day chuckles
s so Zachary I don't know many people
know this Zack
Zachary's been a part of the show for a
long time actually sings the theme to
the show you want to show us yeah first
question to go to you just talk about
the transition from Chuck to this new
character very simple example of the
difference between the two is that Chuck
never killed anyone and and didn't want
to because he had like a really big
heart and he really was very altruistic
in that regard and constant use of tranq
gun and Lou Collins believes in using
the Glock so so that's kind of a big
difference you know Lucas a very
tortured guys he's gone down a very dark
path with his in his in his very twisted
relationship with his wife and we've
been very hurt something that's happened
so yeah he's so no match for Matt
Parkman okay jack
yeah so this whole thing started with a
a Super Bowl teaser spot because
watching the Super Bowl when they soon
as that pit that thing came on we lit up
our text I was like Tim you want oh my
god I couldn't have been happier
what is that tell me tell me when it's
like house had been getting back into
that character he's been amazing the
Halloween came back very quickly and
then once I got my oh my god amazing so
right put your hands up my friend
right after your uh your bet yes I'm an
army vet yeah very very fast always
presented an opportunity of greatness
and an opportunity to change so he takes
it I think yeah in divorce all right
cool I never know what I can say yeah
Robbie Robbie how you doing buddy good
man so you're playing the same character
from Peter Pan in this class today the
exact same cartel tell us about your
role uh he's uh pretty much the opposite
instead of my a British villain I'm now
an American hero now by my character is
Tommy and he's essentially with a
massive secret the secret being that he
has this extraordinary power that he
can't quite control understand the
ability to make other people disappear
and that terrifies him he has no idea
you know where they go whether they just
you know Kumble into the abyss or a
transported somewhere else you have no
idea so that is you know dawning on him
and it's martensite but what he wants to
do is just be a normal you've described
every character on this panel like the
first year of heroes you guys remember
the discovery was just so exciting it
was it was a discovery for the audience
was a discovery for the you know for the
characters and I'm sure for the right of
students to discover who's going to go
where and I'm sure your favorite
character who's your favorite character
right for
oh so Judy let me ask you a question
what's it like working with that you
guys are working a lot together right
it's wonderful experience he's very tall
which is good for me what six foot eight
six foot nine seventy yes MBAs it's
great he's really understands his
character and it really helps me a lot
we get to have a twisted messed-up
relationship on TV and do a lot love
that love that and then we're running
out of time we have so much to show you
guys Gavin tell me okay so Emily is the
character that I play and she's just a
sweet girl next door and she meets Tommy
at school and finds out his big secret
and it's just there alongside him to
help figure out the conflict and gets
tossed in this crazy chaos if he ends up
going through and we go through it
together and so know there's some
bravery to her in very cool yeah erica
kravid think yes you are sheryl sandberg
but bigger vision I by Molina is this
bold and ethereal kind of mysterious
teenage girl she grew up in a very
different upbringing you know from an
early age she was told that she was
destined for greatness so she grew up
just training for entire life for when
that day came hey guys I played Quentin
Frady who's a conspiracy theorist you
kind of saw the beginning of my story
look pretty cool which is pretty awesome
and researching basically there is a
gigantic tragedy that will not go
destruct that pulls me in personally and
I research it and it brings me to no
event
you know what there's way too much
information there's a lot no no there's
a this is nice and we gotta go to about
that we would like to get us to leave
the hall with excitement with just
enough information not too much
information so to help us wipe your
brains ladies and gentlemen please
welcome
don't look them in the eye look him in
the eye by the way these are just a
small representation of the cafe
representations but there are so people
that are missing that they're working
and they couldn't be here one of which
is is a well he's sent a message for all
of us because he couldn't be here so
let's uh let's roll that message right
now
argument Jeff do you believe this
I think this is time we should open up
the questions I know you guys have a lot
of questions for these guys let's get
right to it where's our there we are how
are you I'm doing great next question
coming as recurring characters well I
think the trailer kind of answered that
question and I'm standing up here not
for my health Jack's here but to talk
about exactly how this has just brewed
on yeah who could you get could you get
along everything wasn't a matter of who
we could get who we couldn't get it was
really what the story was dictating and
as we were breaking the story when it
when we started to think well wouldn't
it be great if Matt Parkman came back in
a different way that's how kind of how
it works so it was said out of Tim I'm
sorry losers so that's kind of how it
worked and and we were able to get you
know obviously Massey and Greg and
Christine rose and Kendall Ramamurthy
yeah so you know but the lynchpin from
the former cast was was Jack and his
character and you know from watching the
first series
you know Jay Choji was kind of a hub
character that a lot of the other
stories fun off of and so it was really
important for me to bring him back and
also tell him that the only character
that sort of came back in that way was
the character that didn't have any power
so we never survives that's a lesson
there hi my name's Chris big fan of the
show and follow me and since day one but
we saw through seasons one through four
everyone discovering new powers and new
people but now we see in this new season
they're being hunted and now it looks
like HDR is trying to save them HRG
Flemington with Skylar everybody has to
be about Skylar you know the basic
premise because the world knows about
these people you know it changes the
story considerably before in the
previous series when you discovered you
out of power it was almost a kind of a
mystical like what's happening to me in
a whole journey of discovery now because
if you were to wake up with a power in
our story it would be a very very bad
thing because you would know that you
were going to be persecuted and
Exploited and all of that and so it
takes the the basic idea of the showing
it cranks it up a little bit puts a
little bit more kind of a little bit
more stakes and a little more drama and
when you think about it the way we went
off the air was kind of the best pilot
possible
you know Hayden's character saying we're
out here and reviewing this to the whole
world
it's really exciting I've seen a lot
more than you guys have seen in space
okay this show is back and it's gonna be
amazing
you played my favorite Disney Prince and
you have career goals such as music
before acting and will you ever operate
your singing voice into your trim work
again yeah I mean I grew up doing a lot
of theater
Stevens like you go tonight did a lot of
musical there's another spot right
behind you I don't know what's happening
and I love doing musical theater so I
would like to do more singing it's just
it's always a matter of thank you very
much but it's always said its life is
time right it's you know figuring out
how do you divvy up that time and right
now the time was of what was presented
to me was this I when this project was
announced that you know the Tim was
making heroes reborn I was a fan of the
show we got to be on NBC together on the
same night and I loved playing chart and
it was always kind of really secret the
enemy is that I couldn't fly if she
plays her from my
although I didn't know kung-fu and so so
I you know we got the toxins in and I
talked and to me that that felt like the
best use of my time for right now and
I'm still trying to convince him to let
Luke say so well dusting every this job
it's just so we have to tell him to stop
saying - a it's a taste I'm like
meatloaf meets Shania Twain question for
box mr. Massey oka how are you my friend
Massey honestly creatively I mean I know
you and I of the state very good friends
yet Massey is the reason why I've been
on the whole y5o a couple times and
we've had some really and you're amazing
what was your first thought when you saw
a promo you probably win if everybody
knew that the show was coming back but
like what not just because you could
travel time but because you know what
was your first thought I thought it was
it was just awesome
you know it's a show that was dear to
our heart and we had a lot of fans and
we kind of left it kind of you know
unfinished so just to see that it was
like oh great
there's been another series and just a
chance to wrap things up at least for
the fans and I'll bring it back so it
was it was very cool I hope that they
would call us you know you know there's
been a part of it I know some of us went
off and did other projects other people
stayed loyal to the brand
yes you know that this is a really fun
idea that there is this big gap that we
need to explore and some of the kind of
ancillary stuff that we're doing the
universe that we're building around the
show and the games and books and all you
know does all that but that is a big
part a lot of that does get unpacked in
the in the show heroes reborn we do sort
of unpack what happened in the previous
years so I think by the time you know
you watch the finale episode 13 you'll
have a big chunk of that answer for you
and I got to in you know for people that
might catch up the app it's no joke this
is an amazing app the heroes app and all
it is is a love letter to you guys it is
so well built and so well done there's
so much video content you can do it by
character you can do it by episode by
season so check it out before September
24th because it'll catch you right back
up where we were and then you know
obviously jump on dark matters in it as
well yeah dark matters is incredible the
app doesn't have any coupons but you
know whatever since it's awesome
next Buster I thank you for being here
great show like this there's great music
and so
commence parsing we heard my morning
jacket's chills what other great bands
are then come back promise you
soundtrack
oh we're sort of still in the works with
all of that because it doesn't those
things don't get finalized until it airs
but you know as you know that the show
was very interested in music before and
when the élysée are back doing our score
and you know with them comes a whole
bunch of opportunities because they're
kind of like you know rock star royalty
in that Los Angeles and so you get you
get access to a lot of really
interesting new new bands and we always
liked actually breaking new music that
people you know haven't heard before and
so but yeah I'm sorry I can't announce
any of it right now tell us a little bit
more about a charging now HRT now well
five years later you know trying to put
a more of a suburban quiet life out of
you know off the grid but totally lasts
as long as this wild man with the ginger
beer down here shows torment me and
there's there's certain incidents in my
brain my memory which I are lacking and
he's there to fill in the gaps gaps I
don't necessarily want filled in and
then who shows up to rip your brain to
shred well this you know there's a guy
that's always trying to get inside my
brain trying to find out what happened
from LA yeah I have to say that was
incredibly cool like to go and go back
home said everybody has been amazing you
know it was strange
honestly strange going back I don't know
Moss you know Johnny you can even talk
about this but to go back on a show that
you were so incredibly lucky to be a
part of and it really changed my career
and was they introduced me to whatever
is 7508 thousand of my best friends in
this room it really was such a
yeah I found so much going back he's
felt like you know putting on old jacket
again is great I have to do it just
quickly to correct the great game up did
the first see you know I was standing
off camera and you know we had just sort
of joked to talk before I'd look in the
camera roll and he did the first thing
you looked at back and nothing needed to
be said yes it was like this instant
sort of five years disappeared and you
were back to playing that character yeah
I was it was like the time we met at TGI
Fridays we looked across the bar and
nothing you didn't be said next question
yes what you guys finished here oh it's
the first time where it took a break
there was a lot of expanding universe at
comics web content how much of that are
you keeping Canon and how much we're
just getting a Star Wars wave it away no
the answer is the Canon of show remains
intact
this is very true to the you know to the
pathology and the core Canon of the show
we're not we're not deviating from
anything so it's all we really want to
honor anybody who spend that much time
watching that many episodes yeah and
Star Wars I can't talk about next
question
my question is for the entire cast um if
your character on the show can have a
superhero named Dan Mahoney who knows
how can I took that I have to say I came
up with mine in the elevator on their
way up here and I'll show you again from
the DVD extra super vaginas my nickname
in high school
that's awesome keep it going
I think I probably call myself the
burrito Lord something that has cheese
in it because my name is cathlin green
so it was relates my cart ride city call
in the magician that's gone that's well
I'm gonna get your drinks and then I'll
come back sure
I will be Oh
Zach benedict cumberbatch
Tim I've never sports heroes often tent
the big man upstairs I always do what
he's the guy in the office upstairs and
that's who I thank for for giving us
this opportunity Massey you brought
something with you didn't do some
special whip they might like to show the
clip in a trailer it's a little bit from
my character dusting off the sword yeah
doing a little bit dark mall style so we
kind of I think we remind these people
September 24th NBC heroes reborn
you
you